the former president of the european
council donald tusk is staging a
political comeback in his homeland
poland tusk is taking over as leader of
the main opposition party the liberal
civic platform
he wants to challenge yaroslav kashinsky
of the ruling right-wing law and justice
party
in elections in two years time the
government has clashed with brussels
over law reforms
and lgbt and women's rights
and joining me now from warsaw is uw
correspondent magdalena palocat
magdalena thanks for being here donald
tusk is back
uh what does all this mean
well we never know what it means but we
know he could be dangerous for the
ruling party for yaroslav kaczynski and
we know that
he has ambitions to win the next
election
will which will take place in two years
in poland
and his ambition is for now that and
it's clear he will
fight derose of kaczynski that's his aim
if it's going to happen
we still have two years so we have to um
to what to look what's going to happen
but he came back you know to his
party he came back to civil platform
which he co-founded two decades ago
and he feels like home here which we
could see today he was very um
positive he was very self-confident and
he said he will give courage to his
party to win the next elections well
let's see okay so he's back in the game
what agenda does he have how does he
want to change the country
well he did not say um a lot today about
his political agenda he didn't talk
about
internal affairs and politics but what
he said and
what reminded me a little bit of joe
biden
is that um poland in poland needs to be
back
he said also about himself i'm 100
back and poland has to be also back and
he um said he would like to repair
poland's reputation in the world
and reestablish poland to be a respected
country in the international
area so um that's what we heard today
from him he didn't talk a lot about his
political agenda but it was although
this
a very strong sign that he is back
okay he's back he wants pauline to be
back someone else who's back as you know
better than eyes yaroslav kaczynski
reelected
as the leader of the governing right
wing populist law and justice party
so who wins the fight between the two
men
huh that's a good question but donald
tusk is i think the only one now who
could be really dangerous for yarisov
kaczynski and you know
when we uh so today yerushav kaczynski
um speaking and donald tusk speaking
you know normally all cameras would uh
look at thearosoft kaczynski and today
they changed their roles so it seemed
already today
dangerous for kaczynski but as i said we
have two years
and we don't know what's going on with
the economical situation which looks
quite good now
we don't know how the internal fights in
the ruling peace party
will develop and um it's hard to predict
now but
you know once donald tusk already won
an election against kaczynski that was
2007
so um people who watch him now
say maybe he could repeat it
but let's wait okay well thank you for
that insight and we'll be of course
watching that contest very closely
magdalena gloucest palace in warsaw
thanks so much for that
insight and return of donald tusk to
polish politics
you